[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad vamos a
hablar del rock and roll y es que hace
unos pocos días se celebró el día
mundial del rock y es por eso que vamos
a charlar con bruno larocca él es
periodista especializado en rock escribe
para la revista rolling stones estamos
junto a uno de los máximos referentes de
los más importantes del periodismo de
rock en argentina bruno ahora toca
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
de nada gracias a ustedes bueno pero no
comenzamos hablando de lo que es la
piedra fundacional no de esta
celebración de este día mundial que fue
el live aid de 1985 no que marcó lo que
es el 13 de julio como el día mundial
del rock que hablamos del concierto
benéfico más importante de toda la
historia bueno en realidad eran dos
conciertos en simultáneo no uno en eeuu
otro en inglaterra con 76 estrellas de
la música de todo el mundo reunió a
bruno lo que era la elite de la música
no de aquella época había bandas como
queen you tube black sabbath led
zeppelin muchísimas otras bandas que
buscaban recaudar fondos para combatir
el hambre en áfrica dejó shows
memorables verdad
contanos que uno que representó el live
aid de 1985 qué impacto tuvo
bueno si bien obviamente se toma esta
fecha como referencia adiós permitirá
aclarar que también el rock and roll le
arranca de mucho antes no afines
promediando en los años 50
pero si bien se toma esta fecha como
este evento solidario creo que tuvo una
gran importancia a nivel mundial la
repercusión que tuvo también el espíritu
solidario del rock and roll puesto no
por una causa como fue lo que estaba
pasando con la hambruna en etiopía y
somalia hay en áfrica y que se junten
tantos monstruos de la música a nivel
mundial para para juntar fondos en un
evento que requería no está tanta
necesidad se reunieron más de 100
millones de dólares
en ese día en un show que total fueron
más de 16 horas de música teniendo a los
artistas consagrados incluso algunos
músicos como mick jagger y keith
richards que también participaron por
afuera de los rolling stones pero que
quisieron estar y dijieron presente en
un evento solidario imaginarnos hoy a
queens a paul mccartney a que richard
bueno a mick jagger todos compartiendo
ojos un escenario parece una locura no
bueno eso pasó en 1985 muy afortunados
quienes hayan podido estar allí
presentes pero alguna vez dijiste el
rock genera algo más que cualquier otro
género musical y sobre todo en la
juventud contanos qué es eso que provoca
el rock y que lo diferencia de otros
géneros verdad
bueno es que justamente por lo menos acá
en argentina nosotros entendemos también
el rock como un fenómeno cultural que no
solamente abarca la música sino el rock
nace en argentina también como un
movimiento cultural que no sólo incluía
músicos sino que también incluía a
escritores a poetas a filósofos a
periodistas ella ha promediado los años
en la década del 60 ya empezaban a tener
ciertas inquietudes con lo que tenía que
ver la ecología y el rock por eso digo
de alguna forma fue un movimiento
cultural que excedió incluso lo que es
estrictamente lo que podemos conocer
como rock and roll como género musical
un estilo de vida también no es el rock
and roll quizás eso lo distingue de
otros géneros
si un estilo de vida que en sus
comienzos era mal visto por la sociedad
hoy el rock digamos así como lo
conocemos oa las figuras de rock también
quizás tuvo su momento de auge y de moda
que creo que no es lo que está
ocurriendo hoy en día con el género en
sí pero en esos inicios del rock era un
género mal visto no llevar el pelo largo
vestirse con botas y pantalones de cuero
bueno socialmente ser rockero en un
comienzo en unos inicios cuando esto
recién comenzaba socialmente en por lo
menos en lo que era latinoamerica bueno
era algo más que preocupante no bruno y
en crista para está el rock
hoy en día en qué momento está
atravesando no sólo como género sino
también como bien decía recién no como
movimiento social cultural
bueno hoy por lo menos en latinoamérica
no se ve ya ese fenómeno del rock como
un movimiento cultural sino lo vemos más
como un género musical en sí no como
puede ser el hip hop
en el último tiempo bueno lo que es el
reggaeton el trap han avanzado y han
aparecido nuevos géneros musicales en la
juventud que han ocupado un lugar
protagónico que ha tenido por lo menos
lo que denominamos como rock and roll
quizás como auge en la década de los 80
y me animo a decir también en los 90
donde en latinoamérica empieza bueno el
furor de los videoclips las cadenas de
música el canal mtv
que expandió y llevó el rock a la
masividad en todo el continente
voy a hacer ahora una pregunta bueno es
que es un poco personal pero es muy
pertinente no si tuvieras que decir
cuáles han sido las 5 mejores bandas de
rock de la historia y también las 5
mejores canciones cuáles elegirías
es difícil hablando del rock en general
bueno
yo creo que todo de alguna forma
comienza con los beatles el rock en
latinoamérica también acá en argentina
la aparición de un montón de bandas
tienen que ver con eso con lo que
generaron los beatles el fenómeno la
aparición las películas que comenzaron a
llegar en los años 60 y también un poco
después pero los beats en primer lugar
obviamente los rolling stones the who
zeppelin
y para mí pink floyd no es una banda que
viene un poco después pero que para mí
es una huella para mí dejó una huella
muy muy importante en el rock
y si no estaba pensando el tema
canciones porque bueno ahí es mucho ahí
es mucho más complicado pero pero me
parece que cualquiera de los virus o de
los rolling stones son himnos que
trascendieron a nivel mundial
absolutamente ahora quisiera cambiar
este tema o más bien de región hay
elementos que caracterizan a lo que es
el rock latinoamericano y que los
diferencie del rock del resto del mundo
por uno
si bien el rock latinoamericano siempre
estuvo influenciado con lo que pasaba en
eeuu en el rodaje fue como que siempre
fueron llegando los cambios no la época
en la etapa del rock progresivo la etapa
más pop del rock que se vivió en los 80
con música más bailable
creo que quizás el rock latinoamericano
también fue muy importante en cuanto a
sus letras también con lo que tiene que
ver con los acontecimientos sociales y
políticos que iban al que iba
atravesando este continente no en
latinoamérica estuvo marcada en los años
80 con con las dictaduras militares en
distintos países
que hizo que el rock tuviera mucha
importancia también en ese contexto
social me parece con las letras
combativas creo que eso es una gran
marca que tuvo que tuvo el rock
latinoamericano que quizás no tuvo el
rock en eeuu
y bueno vinculado a esto que estabas
diciendo o bruno crees que sepas o
quizás al menos en la región de américa
latina no de un rock quizás más
combativo o cuestión adorno a un rock
por decirlo de alguna manera un poco más
vacío de esos elementos cuestionadores
del statu quo
sin duda sin duda creo que sí que es así
como vos decías de hecho si volvemos
otra vez un poquito a lo que hablábamos
al comienzo de ese rock que nació como
un movimiento cultural en latinoamérica
y acá en argentina
a esos primeros músicos de rock que eran
perseguidos y detenidos en las calles
solamente por llevar el pelo largo o
usar botas a lo que vemos que ocurrió en
los últimos 10 o 15 años con el rock
siendo parte de del mainstream y siendo
parte también de las publicidades no el
rock pasó a hacer algunas formas la
banda de sonido de de publicidad es
decir bueno muchas campañas incluso de
del consumo que el consumo el consumo y
no me refiero al consumo cultural sino
me refiero al consumo de cosas que
combatían las letras en los 60 buenos el
rock termina siendo de alguna forma
la música publicitaria de del consumo de
un montón de marcas bien paradójico sin
lugar a dudas sabremos ahora de otro
tema vamos a hablar del lugar de las
mujeres en el rock y quisiera citar a la
periodista de romina zanelatto que
investigó muchísimo este tema en lo que
es la argentina no de hecho público el
libro brilla la luz para ellas así
plantea algo bien interesante la voy a
citar ella dice que el rock para las
mujeres fue una forma de rebelión dentro
de la rebelión no que ya era el rock no
coincidir con esta mirada
sí sí creo que las mujeres del rock
tuvo que ganar un espacio que ocupa los
últimos los últimos años digamos desde
sus comienzos era un lugar completamente
anegado acá en argentina en los 80 en
los primeros festivales como el barroco
bueno las mujeres eran agredidas en un
escenario pero cuando lo agredía eran
que una cantidad de enormes del público
presente viendo yo le arrojaba monedas
encendedores cualquier objeto que
tuviera a mano por el simple hecho de
ser mujer no por ser inferior en cuanto
al nivel musical ni siquiera eso no la
mujer me parece que
ha tenido que dar una batalla muy
importante para para ocupar un lugar que
es más que merecido no por su arte los
tiempos han cambiado
no sé a mí se me vienen mientras al lado
y estaban esta pregunta se me viene a la
mente un montón de situaciones
horrorosas que se dieron por lo menos
acá en argentina con con con shows
internacionales donde el público ha
llegado de bajar el escenario a más de
una mujer no
y como lo ves esto está cambiando
sí sí en el último tiempo está cambiando
de hecho acá en argentina se instaló la
ley de cupo femenino donde los
productores de cualquier evento o
espectáculo musical masivo no de los
festivales de los grandes festivales que
tenemos acá en el país tiene que haber
un cupo destinado un espacio para la
mujer
y eso realmente fue si bien en el
principio cuando se instaló esto que es
una ley que fue aprobada y generó alguna
controversia
más allá de esto de la ley en sí que es
un poco también lamentable no que sea
necesario una ley para incluir a la
mujer efectivamente ayer no hayamos
llegado a atender que implementar una
ley
en el último tiempo ha sido cambiado y
ha sido la figura femeninas en el rock
pero que han sido o están siendo vistas
de otra manera tenemos a maria burton y
que ganó un premio gardel a la música
nos ultra hace tres años
ha cobrado un lugar mucho más
protagónico que bueno quería hablar de
hace una década atrás no pero que se
pasó rapidísimo esta entrevista
quisieras continuar dialogando contigo
pero bueno debemos terminar muchísimas
gracias por tu presencia en france 24
augusto santiago y bueno gracias por el
llamado y el contacto no por favor
gracias a vos ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en france 24 y en france
24 punto com
[Música]
y